February might be the shortest month of the
year, but Netflix still has a long list of
new offerings coming your way.
Whether you're craving amazing action or dizzying
drama, there's something for everyone.
From horror to hilarity, it's all here for
your viewing pleasure in February.
Looking for some action?
You've come to the right place.
Beginning February 1st, you can check out
Dirty Harry, the 1971 film that first introduced
us to Clint Eastwood's iconic detective.
You know the one.
"You could ask yourself a question: Do I feel
lucky?"
The 1967 classic The Dirty Dozen is also coming
to Netflix on February 1st.
It tells the tale of twelve Death Row convicts
who improbably become soliders, infiltrating
a Nazi powwow just before D-Day.
Go team!
If you're looking for altogether lighter fare,
there's always The Other Guys, a buddy-cop
film starring Will Ferrell and Mark Wahlberg.
When a minor case unearths a much more serious
crime, two down-on-their-luck cops realize
they have the perfect chance to prove their
mettle.
Here's a tantalizing taste of what these down-to-earth
crimefighters can do.
"Who's got the golden goose now, huh?"
The Other Guys starts streaming on February
1st.
Craving sci-fi served with a side of satire?
Starship Troopers will surely hit the spot.
Directed by inscrutable Dutch provocateur
Paul Verhoeven, the film involves an all-out
war between Earth and a bunch of extraterrestrial
bugs.
But it also serves as a fantastic military
satire.
This underrated gem really piles on the gore
and hammy acting.
Did we mention the alien insects?
[Aliens screeching.]
Starship Troopers hurdles your way on February
15th.
Fans of Blade Runner will definitely want
to check out Ridley Scott's Final Cut.
Yes, it's just one of many versions of the
film - but this is the only one where Scott
had complete creative control over every frame.
The sci-fi opus starts streaming on February
1st.
If you've never seen it before, here's your
chance - so run, don't walk.
There's so much gut-wrenching drama coming
to Netflix in February, so go ahead and consider
your world effectively shattered.
First up: Roman Polanski's The Pianist, starring
Adrien Brody.
Based on a true story, it involves a classical
musician who manages to survive the Holocaust
against incredible odds.
The film - which won three Academy Awards
- hits the streamer on February 1st.
Then there's Driving Miss Daisy, the 1989
drama starring Morgan Freeman and Jessica
Tandy.
It depicts the burgeoning friendship between
a headstrong widow and her supernaturally
patient chauffeur.
The film won four Oscars, including Best Picture,
and it's coming your way on February 1st.
Last but not least, Prince's semi-autobiographical
musical drama Purple Rain also starts streaming
on February 1st.
It tells the story of a fiery young musician
whose band is about to make it big.
The film deservedly took home an Academy Award
for the score, which features "Let's Go Crazy,"
"When Doves Cry," and the epic title track.
Here's an icebreaker for you: Do you like
the Police Academy movies?
If so, February is officially your month.
Seven installments of the comedy series are
coming to the streamer on February 1st.
And while you're at it, why not throw Scary
Movie 2 and A Haunted House into the mix?
They start streaming on February 1st and February
21st, respectively.
Here's a little teaser for you:
"What happened to your furniture, 'cuz?"
Sex and the City 2 also starts streaming February
1st, and it goes a little something like this:
"What do you think?"
"This is fabulous!" *phone rings* "There's
my phone!
Oh my god, here's my phone!"
"Who's her long distance provider?"
Want to see something really scary?
Take a good long stare at Polaroid, which
tells the story of a high school outcast who
discovers an old camera — but there's a
catch.
Anyone photographed by the camera comes to
a very grisly end.
Say cheese!
You can start streaming - and screaming - on
February 9th.
Then there's Girl on the Third Floor, the
story of a man who just wants to remodel his
new home and live happily ever after with
his blossoming family.
Unfortunately, this house was born bad - and
it's out for blood.
Check it out beginning February 22nd.
Finally, there's Every Time I Die, which has
quite the mind-melting plot: After a man meets
an early death, his consciousness keeps zipping
into the bodies of his close friends.
Turns out, he's hoping to protect them from
the same person who killed him.
Will he succeed?
Find out for yourself when the movie starts
streaming on February 25th.
As for TV offerings, we're super-excited for
the first season of Locke & Key, based on
the critically-acclaimed comic book series
written by Joe Hill.
Expect lots of near-indescribable weirdness
- our favorite kind.
You can give it a whirl on February 7th.
On the comedy side, there's only one new stand-up
set coming to Netflix in February 2020, but
it should be quite the doozy.
On February 4th, veteran comic Tom Papa drops
his fifth set of all-new material, You're
Doing Great!
For the uninitiated, here's Papa talking about
his daughter:
"We have a Mean Girl.
Yeah, I didn't know they were real.
I feel guilty.
I made it, I feed it, I'm keeping it alive."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.